so Margaret too is with Calgary Board of
Education she's a psychologist and an
expert in school-based trauma-informed
practice she co-developed the trauma
sensitive Schools Initiative which
includes K to 12 schools as well as
unique educational settings she has
worked with schools in this specialized
area for over 10 years
collaborating with numerous
multidisciplinary teams to support
schools in their efforts to create safe
and caring learning environments
margaret works with the risk and
resiliency team responsible for
assessing and mitigating risk through
trauma lens so thank you yeah we're just
unfortunate just giving you a snapshot
today of our world in education and I've
had the real privilege as a psychologist
who work with I always say Rockstar
educators along the way and other
multidisciplinary people who have really
informed our work and we've done a lot
of Trident have tried a lot of things
that really didn't work so we've learned
from experience along the way so we're
just gonna share with you or I'm up now
gonna share with you some of those
pieces that we've learned and how we you
framed some of this work so I'm just
gonna start with a paradigm shift so
this is I hear this idea of a paradigm
shift in lots of conversations both
within education and with all
stakeholders and so I just want to
highlight what we mean when we talk
about that paradigm shift because I as
I'm doing more of this work I'm
realizing that maybe there is even more
than one shift or that there's a couple
of things influencing the shift so for
those who have heard the term I was
gonna keep that trauma-informed lens a
little bit for this for our purposes
today but really starting to shift that
between what's wrong with you - what has
happened to you
and I think when we start to have any
exposure to the science you start to
realize that that's a good question to
be asking you know in your in a school
community and we have kids who are
behaving in ways that perhaps might
think seeing a child I'm thinking
totally out of control
absolutely not dude math not able
doesn't you know follow any kind of
instruction
they're basically rockin and rollin in
my building what's going on
and if I'm just looking at the behavior
I am completely missing what's driving
the bus and what's going on for this kid
so a simple shift from starting to
wonder but what's happened to this kid
actually starts to open up opportunities
to perhaps look at things differently
and I'm tell you that the more often
when we can shift perspectives that
people are looking at a child's behavior
to the what's wrong with you and they
can get a little bit of information
they're nine times out of ten then we
start to see educators and those in
school buildings say I can work with
this kid it's a big shift the other
piece of the shift that I want to talk
about is when we take a look at working
with educators they often say to you I
really want I want the tool the strategy
the intervention that's the most common
question I get so here's the thing
there's no magic bullet so what we have
to start to realize is is when you walk
through a school building if you get
those opportunities and if you're
watching good teaching practice we
actually know a lot in a school
community about how to work with our
kids who've had adverse experiences and
are going through tough times and have
deficits but what we have to make the
shift in is that the paradigm is adding
the science to what we do in terms of
our teaching so that it notches it up
and helps us move through this different
sense of how won't work with kids so
this paradigm is a bit of a challenge
for those in education because really if
I've got this many kids if I had 80% of
my kids in the classroom just
the Magic Bullet thanks very much
because I actually don't have a lot of
time to figure out how to do different
things for different kids so that's a
bit of a paradigm in terms of working
with stuff we have to really think about
we're creating those welcoming caring
environments at that universal level
without it we are not you can have the
best interventions on the planet and if
we don't actually have safe learning
environments for kids it's not going to
be very effective
we use the term a trauma lens often to
think about okay so I've got this
science about adversity and toxic stress
and how it might impact functioning and
what the deficits might be but we want
to be really clear about what we mean by
a trauma lens first of all we do not
assume that every behavior that we see
is driven because we have had trauma
exposure or that we have had adverse
experiences so we got to get really
careful about being judged making
judgments making assumptions and also we
want to get curious so for us a trauma
lens just being really curious and
asking the question hey how are you
doing what's going on what's happened to
you that can be what we see is a trauma
lens but we also have to be really
careful to understand it as a
developmental lens right so where are we
at with in terms of chronological stage
with a kid um you know if you got a 17
year old in front of you but they're
actually developmentally at a four year
old having a temper tantrum those are
the things that we start to get really
curious about yeah oh I got this here I
don't have to look up they're awesome so
what we've learned is that just giving
people the science
here's fight flight freeze isn't really
enough so we have found that we needed
some approaches to help us guide
practice so I'm going to touch briefly
today on the arc framework attachment
self-regulation and competency it's what
we have used and what we have found to
be most useful and helpful for us in
translating a lot of this practice into
education others may be familiar with
neuro sequential model of therapeutics
sanctuary model all of those can be from
a trauma-informed lens the bottoms ones
cognitive behavioral
for trauma and school's sake seeking
safety and sparks are more like
traumaspecific interventions where you
would have those who would be working in
a school who have specific training in
those areas tripping over myself here
all right so weird
I'm gonna just take a look at those
however we got to be really careful
there's a lot of great stuff happening
schools already so we sometimes get
ourselves a little caught in education I
get I am by the way I came from the
corporate world so it's been a good
observational time over the years to
learn these different worlds and what I
started to notice a lot was we talking
either or in a lot of times rather I
really hope we could start to really do
it's the end so when we're looking in
schools we got to pay a lot of attention
to what's already working because I
never tell you there's not a school I
walk into where stuff isn't already
working so what's working and what are
some places where we actually could
apply some of the science to make change
some things so you may be familiar with
some of those elements as a really quick
drive-by there are other organizations
some of these are in the states that
have taken the time to translate the
science and to practice on the ground so
that's looking at hearts looking at
clear out of Washington State University
by the way they're rock stars in terms
of understanding the science and
education it's Chris blase in his group
budget the heart teaching and learning
and then don't forget if you actually
really keen and want to go home and
Google this stuff Australia because
they're doing great stuff so making
space for learning and calmer classrooms
really really really great stuff that
you can look at okay I'm just gonna jump
to what this arc framework is so it was
developed by Christine ikemen Berg and
dr. Margaret blaustein out of the trauma
center in Brookline Massachusetts and it
is also had they've had a lot of support
and work with dr. Bessel van der Koch
and dr. Joseph in Missoula who you may
be familiar with those if you're
familiar with the world of trauma and
adversity so they have developed this
work that it seeks to recognize factors
that derail normative development and to
work with children families and systems
to build or rebuild healthy
developmental pathways so I will tell
you it was initially designed from a
clinical perspective so now you have to
keep in mind if you have the book and
you're looking at it if you're not a
clinician you have to remember that some
of the pieces in it aren't actually made
for education however when I was with
one of my rock star educators sandy
Taylor Tran we were at a conference and
we tripped over this and she came back
and said I think I got it because from
the lens of an educator who started to
realize that we can apply some of this
science in a framework that matches good
teaching practice so over the times
we've presented this information and
worked with at this point a lot of the
people in education you can see them
nodding because they can see themselves
in it and they can parent you almost
always hear them say well we do that
yeah you do
so when we take a look at it very
quickly the bottom blocks here I have to
walk away sorry this these blocks here
these are your attachment blocks this is
about safety so here you've got you
can't read it it says caregiver asset
management attunement consistent
response routines and rituals
those are your bottom blocks as you move
up identification identification effect
modulation expression and the top blocks
are your competency blocks developmental
tasks executive function and self
development and identity the top block
was added later and it was actually
added for the clinicians because we
needed a block to actually talk about
processing traumatic material that's not
what we're doing how we view that top
block is and when kids are in a space
when they're ready and able to learn so
the bottom part here is critical in
looking at for example these the science
I'm just gonna take one block attunement
the one block will tell you kids could
be overly tuned miss a tune or non
attuned at all
are you seeing the fight flight freeze
response in action have you got
something else going on so if you
actually understand a to marrow neurons
you understand perhaps when you walk
into a room and how people are reading
your cues and what's going on for you
and how you might attuned to your
classroom to individual kids they
actually start to understand the science
you can start to tweak your practice so
this framework we see as being really
helpful in terms of understanding that
when you look through that lens first
thing we do is we create belonging and
safety then we have to modulate you got
to identify it what you're feeling you
got to modulate it and you got to be
able to express it and how we do those
in schools we can do that without
getting into that so called therapeutic
lens and those top blocks the executive
functioning blocks that's what we do we
teach but here I'm here to tell you one
thing if you've got a kid or a classroom
and they're not safe they're offline
they're not getting up here to do your
math I don't it doesn't matter how good
your math program is if kids are
dysregulated in the threat response
state this is where you got to start the
other thing that I can't talk about the
arc framework without talking about
carryover effect management I'm just
here to tell you it's the most important
Block in the framework and time and time
and time again schools will come back to
this is this is where we have to start
because if you have staff that are so
stressed overwhelmed unable to cope
because of the demands of what they have
going on in their buildings and I'm
going to tell you with a lot of these
kids coming in with this level of
adversity it's hard work day today but
we don't create really healthy high
functioning multidisciplinary teams
within school communities that can take
up this work then we're not gonna get
we're not just simply not going to be as
effective as we couldn't should be so
this block critical so it's also a
paradigm because we always want to talk
about the kids and I'm here to tell you
if we don't talk about the adults we're
missing the boat key messages
it's good for all kids critical for our
vulnerable kids based on extensive
research recognizes good practices and
notches it up it's about timing and
intentionality we go back and we talk
about the timing the timing is critical
you can start to understand this could
be a dynamic process but if I'm stuck
here and I need to do the work here then
the in timing isn't gonna work so how do
you apply the science to the timing and
intentionality you may have the best
strategy the best tools and you sitting
with them but if I've got somebody who's
checked out because they're dissociated
perhaps because they're in the threat
state maybe it's just not the time to
use it but when they're regulated and
feel good and comfortable maybe we come
back and we use those oh I'm going the
wrong way
I think sorry about that so really quick
we did some training with a new teacher
cohort Tracy and I and Teresa and I and
we decided there were five fundamental
things to know safety first we've hit
that check yourself before you wreck
yourself what are you bringing into
schools today how are you doing how are
you modulated a gesture ant lens from
what's wrong with you - what has
happened to you and then start peeling
back the layers the more you know the
science the more you can understand
those layers the more effective you're
gonna be then apply what you know
observe modulate and do one minute for
some of our lessons learned we have to
get leadership on board in terms of
helping them understand the science and
why it's relevant we've got it give
people permission to apply that
scientific lens and sometimes that means
flowing down the bus because if we're
talking about in timing and
intentionality we may have to tweak our
practice in order to get the results
what we want small things make a really
big difference if you're going into
schools and we're talking to school
staff that have a lot going on and their
buildings rocking and rolling
we can just tweak practice sometimes
just enough to make a huge difference
for an individual kid or classroom so we
don't have to actually take on the
universe at any one point in time by the
way if the teamwork teamwork teamwork
this we cannot do this work in silos if
you walk into a building and every door
is shut you don't know there's a kid in
the building it's not a good sign
got to go back to how to build the
healthy team so that we're working
together
don't forget secondary traumatic stress
we have to make pay attention to the
cumulative impact on the adults around
us when we're working with kids who've
had really hard things happen to us
we've got to pay attention to the
reality of how hard this work is and
we've got to build in a mechanism for
taking care of the adults the other
piece is walking the walk is harder than
talking the talk and I see that a lot
right so we have to pay attention to
that and I just have to say one less
quick thing I just flew in from Fort
McMurray last night supporting the
schools up there around what they are
doing to get kids back in schools etc
and having been up there and
understanding the paratha evacuation
process I just invite you to never
underestimate the power of a school
community and the extent to which
schools can be safe places for kids and
that what we can do to support one
another because not one child over over
6,000 kids was left behind under extreme
circumstances so the power of a school
community can be really fantastic thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much Margaret and thank
you to all of the speakers for
responding to my stress-induced timing
but that was very good and now time for
questions for Margaret specifically and
then we'll open it up to questions for
all at the back Amy Margaret do you have
any suggestions for advancing team work
and are there groups that are
cross-sectoral in composition in
brackets the orchestra that are going on
already fortunately we do have good
examples of working in those
multidisciplinary teams that will I can
think of even just the our CSD community
they're coming together around the
different lenses
my recommendation is making sure that no
matter what school community that you're
working in make sure you've got fair
representation they're around a table
because sometimes we miss having the
voice of an EI an educational assistant
or some other persons who are working in
the building may we all need to actually
have a voice in order to work together I
would say never move forward without
having both the mental health lens and
the educator lens as a minimum because
we're not talking about introducing a
math curriculum and we really do need to
attend to the issues that can bubble up
for when we're talking about adversity
because when we look at our audience of
course we're looking at kids but we have
a lot of adults who have also had their
own experiences so we have to be able to
have that experience they're totally
answered your question but
other questions in the room I got off
easy Lauren I will pose one that's just
forming as I'm speaking so it may not
come up coherently but the centre has
been quite involved with child and
family services child to youth services
and thinking about trauma-informed care
within those systems and I see an
incredible overlap with what you're
talking about the Model T and MT the
sanctuary model etc and and yet I just
wonder what them the links are with
between you and school systems and the
folks that are working in child
intervention services and child and
youth services given that you're talking
the same talk are there ways in which
mechanisms that you're actually working
together systems yeah I think the common
frame often now is talking about
trauma-informed practice as a frame so
that kind of goes it doesn't matter what
industry that you're working in then you
can start to understand how you apply
the science into practice and those
things are important we have a quite a
bit of experience with working with CIAM
Family Services and Alberta Health
Services and others with justice on the
ground using the arc framework maybe not
at the senior level on down but we have
found that the most effective way to
work together is to have a common
language and so when we have those
multidisciplinary teams sitting around
the table and we're all looking through
the lens of the arc framework for us
it's really helpful and I know that some
the thing that's really I didn't say
which I should say is that I caution
around getting too caught up in any one
framework that it's the only frame we
have used the arc framework because we
see how it can apply in education and
educational practice but I remember
about two years ago went to here I was
at a trauma conference in Boston and and
dr. Joseph in Izola was speaking about
these different frameworks and how if we
get too caught up in any one framework
we may not see what the great stuff
that's going on out there
so sometimes
the opportunity might be to combine the
work and so if you have opportunities to
have those who are trained in nmt as an
example and also having school
communities trained in arc there's great
synergy that you can start working
together and that's why I kind of wanted
to comment on it's not the either/or
it's and we know have time for another
question and then we'll open it just
along that line of the question I'm the
education child and family services
liaison for region 3 and I'm the success
in school lead for region 3 which covers
nine school divisions and that's where
Child and Family Services comes together
with education foster parents foster
care support workers who are over else's
in the child's life to trying to ensure
the best education possible so we do
have that provincial initiative hope
that's okay at that Margaret